ou ici vous ne verrez pas de RCK vous ne
verrez pas non plus de plaquage ni de
mêlé car dans le rugby a 5 il n'y a pas
de contact il faut allier à la vitesse
la vitesse et
l'agilité le terrain étant plus petit il
faut donc être assez rapide et pour
faire des passes également rapide afin
de prendre les intervalles pour les
marquer un essai pour arrêter un joueur
il faut arriver à le toucher c'est deain
obligatoire
pas l'une après l'autre et c'est entre
la la taille là et le et les épaules au
bout de si touchés le ballon est donné à
l'adversaire pour le reste les règles du
rugby s'appliquent les passes se font
toujours vers l'arrière avant d'aplatir
le ballon dans l' but un sport qui fait
travailler particulièrement le cardio ça
court pas mal faut on a l'avantage de
pouvoir changer comme on veut sur sur le
terrain AC remplaçant le menestro rugby
Sologne a vu le jour en 2016 il compte
une quinzaine de licen
sur le terrain il n'y a pas de femme
même si le rugby à 5 est mixte mais le
club a réussi à attirer les débutants
anciennement je je jouais plutôt au foot
dans dans un ancien village et venu pour
justement pouvoir faire un petit peu de
sport se dépenser l'esprit d'équipe il y
a pas le le tracas qu'on pourrait avoir
de de se blesser le le weekend ou le
enfin le dimanche ou le weekend et pas
pouvoir aller au boulot ça permet
justement de pouvoir faire une activité
physique entre guillemets non dangereuse
le rugby a 5 séduire les anciens du 15
comme Philippe 63 ans blessé au servical
pendant sa carrière il retrouve les
sensations du rugby mais le touché il en
faisait avant auparavant lorsque les
licences étaient pas autorisé au niveau
de la FFR au mois de juillet au mois
d'août souvent nous jeune on retrouvait
le stade pour pouir jouer avec les
copains et jouer au toucher c'était un
toucher mais c'était pas à 5 mais
c'était un toucher avec un certain
nombre de personnes et ça permettait de
travailler les passes et travailler la
technique individuelle aujourd'hui le
sport a été codifié par la Fédération
Française qui poursuit son développement
dans la région Centre Val de Loire il
existe une trentaine de sections ou de
clubs de rugby à 5